hello I'm Gabe I'm Dan we're the slow mo
guys I've always been interested in how
fire spreads against a sort of solid
horizontal surface yeah and like you
know if you throw a bucket of petrol or
a wall or something yeah I always
thought it'd be cool to look at fire
from the other side of that well like so
as if it was like see-through yeah like
glass
something like glass yeah I this course
yeah not the first time we've done that
joke no so if you throw a bucket of
petrol on fire
so right here hopefully in lovely
glorious 4k slow mode all throughout and
you'll be able to see it again it's like
a flat perfectly in focused surface oh
yeah that's a good point it's gonna be
perfectly in focus because it's a level
plane it seemed like a crossfire
cross-section of fire yeah it should be
lovely and incredibly dangerous please
don't do this at home as you can see
we're not anyone's home we're in a
quarry yeah we've done this in someone
else's quarry yeah okay dangerous
experiments so precautionary measures
are in order
getting the danger suit on so it's like
a flame retardant overalls flame
retardant balaclava goggles flame
retardant gloves offer just a little bit
of petrol is it enjoyable wearing this
on a 37 degree day in Texas hell may I
yeah I'm gonna be positioned there with
the camera zoomed in enough to fill the
frame that's about as far away as I
could be because suddenly a 90 mil and
then we've got we've both got fire
extinguishers you're going to use yours
on the window I'm gonna use mine on the
window well not necessarily the window
but all of the other stuff flammable
cardboard very much in case you need to
do another shot so I'm gonna get
straight in there with the fire
extinguisher and put it right out to
stop any sort of flames and my fire
extinguisher is going to be for you I'm
gonna drag that right close to the
camera and I'll run in and put you out
just in case it all goes wrong if I
haven't put myself out already yeah I
need to pee as well so we also got that
so order of runnings you're gonna like
it you're gonna throw it I'm gonna bag
the camera yep
then you extinguish the cardboard and if
you're on fire I run in the next thing
with you before anything else well
lunch first you ready ready she's gonna
dump my hands in this water okay okay
[Applause]
I'm ready okay I'm gonna go ahead right
here we go
you could be yeah we're good
get the camera good go for it bottom of
the glass nice excellent
there was no splash back on me that's
good but I would have liked to have
thrown it a bit higher on the glass
really because it dropped faster than I
was expecting
well at least fire goes up it's true
it's not like it fell on the floor is
like the main part of it I think the
meat of it was in the middle careful
this might be on fire might not be able
to see it I've put it out I think okay
not the beginning of Watchmen or
something I look very menacing looks
like I'm throwing the fire at you that's
there oh yeah look at that
fluid then when did it hit the glass I
wonder if you can tell there's twisty
vortex yeah they're cool sick is that
all against the fire that's all one
plane of focus right there yeah like
it's not actually coming towards you
anymore at all Wow isn't that I'm happy
with that
that's really nice and obviously a
complete guess on the exposure you know
it looked like it all held yeah you know
it's very yellow in the middle but I
think there's some bright moments there
yeah what was that there's a thousand
friend a second 180 degrees shut up
always an f8 so that was just bit of a
guess there well I think the brightest
parts also you see where the petrol was
still liquid yeah it was like reflecting
the sunlight and that was really bright
yeah look at all this petrol suds just
on fire there's like suds of petrol okay
cheeky bonus shot we just wait for the
Sun to go down so it's much much darker
it may not look darker to this camera
but to the Phantom it's almost
completely pitch black against that
glass so this will be a fire only
version
it looks a lot more with it
[Music]
[Music]
well I don't think I've ever this won't
do with it I mean I suppose the joke
about the winner doesn't really work
when when you can't see it you might
actually see through it
oh yeah okay well I don't think I've
ever seen fire from that angle just to
see the liquid splashing and flowing
onto the glass with fire through it sort
of fire behind it yeah it's weird how it
really goes to show how petrol isn't
actually on fire as such when it's the
liquid it's the vapors that are really
on fire yeah but with you know
temperatures like this and with it
expanding and getting spread through the
air it gives off those vapors like crazy
it really does it's just impossible for
it not to all be on fire at once
should we just lob a brick through this
lovely stuff hopefully you enjoyed that
video make sure you subscribe to the
slow mo guys we also have a second
channel we've just put up a video
featuring Linus tech tips where we added
a hundred and thirty terabytes
to the channels total storage so hop
over there and bung that a watch if
you'd like we'll see you next time
[Music]